Over the last decade, milk has become a bit controversial.
Some people say it's a necessary and nutritious food vital for healthy bones,
but others say it can cause cancer and lead to an early death. So who's right.
And why.
Anyway.
Milk is the basis of every memos diet after birth.
When our digestive systems are immature and small,
basically it's power food to kickstart our bodies and help us grow.
Milk is rich in fat vitamins,
minerals and milk sugar lactose on top of that for a while
after birth,
it also contains antibodies and proteins that protect us from infections and
regulate our immune system. But it's a lot of effort for mothers to produce.
Eventually humans stopped drinking mother's milk and transitioned to the diet of
their parents.
This is how it's been for thousands of years until about 11,000 years
ago. When our ancestors settled down in the first agricultural communities,
soon, they domesticated the first dairy animals, goats, sheep, and cattle.
They found that dairy animals are able to be useless and abundance stuff and
turn it into nutritious and tasty food.
This made a huge difference in terms of survival, especially in hard times.
So groups that had milk available had an evolutionary advantage and through
natural selection, it changed the genes of communities who consumed a lot of it.
This adaptation has to do with a specialized enzyme.
Lactase babies have a lot of it in their system,
so they can break down the milk, sugar, lactose and digest milk easily.
But the older we grow, the fewer lactase enzymes,
our body produces worldwide about 65% of the population do
not have the enzyme after infancy,
which means they are not able to digest more than about 150 minutes is each day.
This lactose intolerance is not spread evenly around the world though,
in some East Asian communities, for example,
it's up to 90% in Northern Europe and North America.
The rates are the lowest overall.
There are probably a few reasons for this uneven distribution.
The trade was first introduced by random mutation,
which happened independently of each other in a few populations.
The fact that farming replaced hunting and gathering more and more created
natural selection, pressure,
people who are able to digest lactose had more foods at hand,
which was an advantage, the migration of dairy farmers to the North,
then spread it further,
which probably pushed back populations there that didn't have the trait.
Okay. But if milk has been a valuable part of our diet for thousands of years,
why is it so controversial?
There are.
Number of claims regarding the negative and positive health effects of milk.
The negative ones cover a wide variety from brittle bones to
cancer and cardiovascular diseases to intolerance and allergies.
So how do they hold up? Some.
Studies found a connection between milk and a high risk of breast colon and
prostate.
Cancer. But.
Metro analyses found no impact on your cancer risk on the country.
The calcium in milk might even have a protective effect against colon cancer.
Although this could be calcium in general,
it's not clear milk plays a role in this effect.
Only studies on prostate cancer showed an increased risk for people who consumed
more than one and a quarter liters of milk a day. But again,
the association is inconsistent and other studies don't find any effects.
We discussed these studies in more detail in our sources document.
All in all the research seems to show that if you drink between 100 to 250
milliliters of milk per day, cancer is not a concern.
Similarly.
Meta analyses could not find any impact from milk or dairy products on your risk
of heart disease stroke, or your total mortality.
Some studies even suggested that high blood pressure might be rarer in people
who eat a lot of dairy.
Although the evidence is not strong enough to claim this with confidence.
The case gets more complicated though. When we look at boats,
a number of studies found neither positive nor negative effects for adults.
What most people worry most about though, are harmful amounts of pesticides,
antibiotics, or hormones. There are hormones in milk,
but only in very low concentrations. For example,
to get the same amount of hormones as from the pill,
you'd need to drink about 5,000 liters of milk. And even if you did,
most hormones would be destroyed by your digestive system before they could
affect you,
which is the reason why so much medication is coated to protect it from our
digestion for pesticides and antibiotics.
There are regulations in most parts of the world that only allow completely
harmless amounts milk that surpasses these thresholds is not allowed to
go on the shelf.
So there's nothing in particular to worry about besides allergies and those
suffering from lactose intolerance is the best known negative effects of milk of
probably acne and general discomfort after drinking milk or eating dairy
products. And here the effects are very real. For example,
skimmed milk has been found to statistically increase the rate of acne by
24% outages against milk products are especially prevalent among children
with one in 18 kids in Germany, suffering from them. In general,
these outages tend to get better or disappear as they grow older, though.
Okay, is milk healthy, then milk? No matter it comes from mothers,
cows, sheep, goats, or camels is a nutrient dense food.
It contains all necessary macro nutrients and many micronutrients,
especially in regions where people struggle to get enough calories,
milk can contribute to a healthy life and lower child mortality.
For those living in the developed world in general, milk is not harmful.
If you are not allergic or intolerant to it, especially for children,
it's a good way to get large amounts of calcium and for vegetarians,
it's a good source of vitamin B12 and B vitamins in general.
This does not mean there are not other alternatives with the same effects.
You do not need to drink milk to be healthy.
Milk is also definitely not a substitute for water.
Milk is power food and the additional calories from drinking.
A lot of it on a regular basis can contribute to being overweight,
especially flavored milk or chocolate milk is more comparable to beverages like
lemonade than a healthy snack.
And there's another thing to consider milk production has a significant impact
on the global climate.
About 33% of cropland is used to feed grazing animals,
including dairy cattle,
even though the carbon footprint of dairy products has declined since 1990 dairy
production is still responsible for 3% of all greenhouse gas emissions,
even more than all aeroplanes combined milk is a huge industry.
And most of its production in factory farms causes incredible suffering.
Cows are impregnated over and over separated from their young shortly after
birth and slaughtered. Once they're tortured, bodies are not productive anymore.
We can't ignore that much of the milk.
We consume stems from an industry that is basically torture and contributes to
climate change was about plant based milk in
terms of protein levels and nutritional value.
Only soy milk can compare to cow milk.
The others need to be artificially enriched to reach similar levels of vitamins
and calcium so they can be an alternative to,
and another option might be available. Soon.
Several startups have created non-animal milk that is nutritionally identical to
dairy milk. For example, through fermentation by gene modified bacteria area
slapped, grown milk can even be turned into cheese.
Something that plant-based alternatives struggle with because they lack casein
and whey protein. The key ingredients that give dairy its taste and structure,
the environmental impacts is a different story though.
Many local tentatives use significantly less energy land and less water to
produce. So they have a much lower environmental impact than animal milk.
If you want to have the lowest possible negative impact on the planet,
the best choice is whatever mill called tentative as regional
as with almost any topic. Milk is complicated.
It's not harmful for the majority of the population.
And it's crucial for many people around the world. It's good, nutritious food,
but also harmful to the planet and causes a lot of suffering.
We need to decide as a society, how we want to deal with these facts.
[Inaudible].